hello to reject nation Greg Alva here
I'm still sick still we're in same shirt
but a watched episode 5 yesterday
stranger thinks part 2 and yeah I'm
really liking this show with odd and I
thought this is ringing in my ear just
won't go away I'm sure you guys are sick
of hearing me say it will imagine living
winning chapter 6 the spy let's get this
on the show Road whatever the words are
and also I can only show about 10
minutes of footage so I got to condense
it down but also in TV shows
he's gonna die if that isn't a line
instead of someone's dead don't you
leave him Samwise I'm gonna promise mr.
fertile I really like those two together
oh I'm kind of hoping Bob is a doc you
really feel like they would give does
make sense to kill them off Sean Astin
Bob's big guy no just me
Oh No like burn off a brain cell or
something
[Music]
[Music]
if you already
oh man house that would be if they kill
off will
[Music]
right these nipples the chills are so
hard right now it's only actual soccer
for this cute you see um okay what's
going on
I'm gonna eyes if you doing know
you sure if it's gonna talk what my
background looks really green screens
taking the bait y'see nothing to be
[Music]
no I really like Steve you stayed this
guy he's like the Jamie Lannister the
show oh haha Steve you're so cool Wow
shadows though does make that hair look
sexy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's awesome he's Steve
[Music]
dami so cool what no
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh No what's happening how there's so
many of them
[Music]
hours
[Music]
the virus duplicators
[Music]
it's scarier with the speakers right
here oh snap
oh it's past memories are John and I all
over again this is this feels almost
exactly like aliens
they're looking at the the radar and
that the design this looks like it is
exactly like aliens I kind of love it
and then there's multiple organs
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sorry
oh well no oh no the Xenomorphs are
gonna get
[Music]
[ __ ] well
this will fill any of those bullets that
are not hitting
[Music]
well I'll detail you see the reflection
into the mask Oh Paul Rizer we are mad
about you Paul Reiser
oh my god so scared
there's so many you know I kind of love
it I feel like the comparator gals shut
up for this is about to end anyway isn't
it all meanness music okay so first off
I'm loving the interaction between dusty
and Steve this is one of the highlights
of the series to me just these two
teaming up having to work together they
play perfectly off of each other I love
it when shows really mixed like when you
get to really know characters in one
season and they might have their own
specific interactions and you mix up the
interactions and dusty and Steve perfect
oh my gosh John and I should be them for
Halloween and Winona Ryder honestly in
the first season she kind of got on my
nerves a little bit I think she did for
quite a bit of people but I really do
believe her in this episode that moment
when she is yelling at the doctors me
can anyone here tell me what is wrong
with my son that was a powerful powerful
active moment and I love seeing how Paul
Reiser's character that was doctor name
I can't remember even there's subtitles
here you really see that he cares about
will conspiracy theorist guy he's kind
of funny but he ultimately he just seems
sort of pretty creepy to me I'm glad
that Nancy and Jonathan are finally
hooking up this episode has led me to a
couple of predictions I don't know which
ones I'm gonna be right about cuz I have
successfully managed to avoid any and
all spoilers to stranger things
surprising these social media has been
pretty cool about it my prediction would
be one Bob's gonna die it just seems
like they're really setting him up to
have some type of who I'm just Bob noob
you know this kind of thing doesn't
happen to me
ain't no B superhero yeah okay the
health sounds like okay they're gonna
probably go to some heroic death and he
Sean Astin I'm sure they only have him
for the season he's not booked to be a
complete series regular you know I don't
really know what's guys doing anymore so
I'm sure he has the time to do it other
season if he wants but my guess he's
probably gonna die some her okay
other guesses because they had Jonathan
my other guess is that because they had
Jonathan and Nancy you know hooking up
on Episode six that they probably might
not end up back together they can't tell
what are Stephen her officially broken
up or did she cheat on Steve and Steve
seems like said Steve I've just loved
Steve now I could they how they've
written his character in this new
direction of the guy helping out the
young kids and he just seems like that
cool older brother her in that situation
who believes in these kids been probably
a lot of other people wouldn't because
he's been witnessed to a lot of things
and has had to help in situations as
well and I really love how they've
changed his character around I love him
and I feel like maybe having daiquiri
Montgomery around even though I still
feel his character's ultimately kind of
pointless to this show I feel like it
kind of replaces you know how Steve was
kind of the bully of the season one now
we got a really just terrible dude and
then you have Steve who's really taking
a shift I love him here my guess is that
Nancy and Jonathan will not be together
in the answer yeah Bob is gonna die
Nancy and Jonathan won't be don't know
how they're gonna get out of this
situation it was great but yeah that was
really intense man I mean seeing how the
upside down is really manipulating will
and that if you heard it it kills will
kills boo I'm thinking to my self I
would hate it it I don't think though
they'll kill off will
I highly doubt I feel like that would
have been on social media by now since
I'm so late to this show that it would
be out there but I'm going to assume
that they don't although I'm is making
me wonder how are they gonna kill or get
rid of this thing inside of him I have
no idea so we'll really see the point of
Mad Max dads die I get it love triangle
yeah that's kind of reminiscent of other
things we've seen but still it's IIIi
don't really see the purpose she serves
that's intense that's intense and I like
the aliens tribute I'm not sure how
people are really responding to multiple
demo Gorgons I think it's cool because
you know they're just continuing their
direct tributes and how a story like
this might actually unfold and that is
pretty scary to know there's
of them and they're all kind of young so
they're not as advanced alright guys
well you can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell make sure to follow me on social
media I really like to use my Instagram
and also check out our patreon become a
patreon eject today I think I'm gonna
watch one more right now